bro when you think about uh the
metaverse uh you started to kind of go
down that path a little bit i know that
you're really excited about this where
do you think uh one that kind of starts
to really permeate society and then also
two how do you think about it from an
investor seat in terms of how to get
exposure to it for your own portfolio
i think if it's the ongoing process the
fact that you and i when we did this the
last interview in 20 not the last one
that that that big interview in 2020 we
had to do in person
right now
you assume right we're now living
digitally
and me seeing you i mean i have you know
drinks with friends on zoom it's normal
now i don't it doesn't bother me right
so we've now moved a massive step into
the digital world where just meeting our
friends or meeting people we know can
happen over video link and we don't
really care much like to happen with
mobile phones and phones before that
and television and all of these things
so this is an ongoing move into the
digital world and then it accelerates
because you start to see the rise of
cryptocurrency and that enables these
ecosystems to develop into these rich
worlds where you can create value
exchange value own things so this
creates the other layer then the layers
on top of that come 5g distributed
computing power and a bunch of other
things that are going to scale that
faster
so once you've got the computing power
because right now most of our computers
are not gaming computers so we can't
render in the speed we need to render so
we get left with crypto voxels and
decentraland being clunky and all of the
cool kids are on epic games and they've
got 4k but we don't have the computing
power to do it
all of that is going to change so all
this is the metaverse it gets thought of
in so many ways for me it's like our
digital fluidity where we can live and
move around in this digital space
interacts with our physical space
whether it's through augmented reality
virtual reality
uh just normal kind of
digital world
and we can kind of
create lives within it so we're creating
income streams we're seeing that with
actually infinity right now or we can we
can be educated in the metaverse that
kind of levels the playing field i mean
you can be a kid in ethiopia and you can
therefore
now get educated on the same playing
field as somebody in the united states
because we have access and you can be in
the same classroom and get to talk to
them so
just things everywhere are going to
change because of this and you know it's
going to happen
because
everybody from microsoft to facebook to
apple have basically said this is the
bet it's augmented reality virtual
reality the metaverse you know i spoke
to the head of metaverse who knew there
was one at aws
and they're building out the computing
power and the cloud storage abilities
for all of these massive compute needs
right so it's happening now the battle
is going to be as ever
the same battle decentralized versus
centralized and as ever it'll be a
mixture of both and we get to choose
um but that's all coming and that's a
hugely exciting thing and people haven't
really figured this out yet but again
it's going to be an enormous generator
of wealth as the world moves into the
digital world i got two more questions
for you first one is around regulation
what's up guys bang bang a bunch of you
want to bring that trillionaire energy
every day and if you want to do it in
your financial life go use sofi sofa is
our exclusive sponsor because we think
they've got a great piece of software
that will help you accomplish your
financial dreams go to sofi.com today to
get started you can invest in everything
from etfs to individual stocks to
cryptocurrencies to ipos and they even
have an automated and best function head
on over to sofi.com
today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]